[Music]
all right so we're gonna do something a
little new today because as you know
almost all the articles are about Kobe
Kobe and we thought we'd take our minds
off of that and do a little bit of a
game so JK as you may or may not know if
you've been tuning in for a while is
pretty much known for their tangents we
start with the news article but then we
always end up on doing all these random
tangents as quickly as we just did a
listicle why not do a video where it's
just hinges like we just go out on
tangents so how this will work is
however there's on without you let's
start with the word you just scream
[Laughter]
start with a word and then one person
will start and they'll start taking
telling a story that reminds them that
of that word and then if at any point
you get reminded of a story in your life
like a personal story you go that
reminds me of this time that I did bla
bla bla
for example for example give me a word
tennis tennis okay
I heard tennis tennis reminds me at this
one time when I was a kid and my friend
from junior high invited me to their
fancy like Court what does it call those
like Clubhouse type Country Club yeah
but you had to have a collared shirt if
you were gonna play tennis there and my
broke ass did not have any collared
shirts and it was really embarrassing
like I didn't know that people our age
even had collared shirts I was 12 years
old and so I had to borrow her shirt but
she was like wait I'm here though no it
was very uncomfortable I felt super out
of my element and judged okay and then
so at any point in this story if you get
reminded of something from your own life
maybe something that colored shirts
reminds me of when I used to go to this
store called Express and I like this one
shirt the way that it looked on me so
much it was this black polo shirt I
liked it so much that I bought like
three of them but the fifty bucks each
I was like this will last me like this
will last me like a couple years a
couple years there's a good quality
thought that because if you're at a
store and you spend more money on
something better quality so you can wash
it more and all [ __ ] but what I didn't
know is that I was going to shrink those
shirts in like [ __ ] three days so I
[ __ ] the shirts up like with no time
and basically heads back to just having
one dry clean
I didn't even think of it I didn't think
of dry cleaning but what do you say
express it makes me think of dress
shirts and ever since I started wearing
dress shirts one thing that I really
liked about them is that you know
there's that plastic thing yeah yeah -
really hole fold the collar down you
kept in it so I have a whole ziploc bag
collection of them because I realized
all dress shirts they're like callers
are actually different lengths so
sometimes when you take them out from
the dry cleaners like if you don't take
them out they'll just throw them away
and you get it back without the minute
you know what the hell and maybe save
like a little hoard so I have a whole
collection to make sure that they fit
the perfect ones oh my god what are you
talking about collections it kinda
reminds me of the fact that since I was
a child for some odd reason it was
ingrained in me that whenever you get an
extra button and any piece of clothing
yeah I have to save it right I just have
to you might need it later you might do
that I do that - I have a whole
Tupperware and this piece of Tupperware
was my mom's Tupperware so this stuff
works from like the 80s is a yellow
pointed no it's actually really good
condition
like she got some really good shape some
some TV sealing yeah and so until this
day Indian it it stressed me out so much
because finally the moment I needed a
button that was one shirt it was this
brand new shirt I don't know what
happened but it popped out and I saved
that but or I thought I saved the button
and I had never once worn it in public
because immediately when I got this
shirt it just like the button fell off
and that shirt the button was critical
or else my titties were gonna come out
and I couldn't find that button I was so
upset because I'm like I've been saving
buttons for years that button was the
Deathstar flaw it was
all system comes apart all of it what if
you take the button from Mike over here
no so it was a particular button you had
like designs on it and it was a really
wild shirt a button that got away yeah
are you sure that you put the button in
the top work container well I guess I
didn't because I couldn't find it pearl
to this day I still save my buttons have
you talking about double-sided tape no
because I'm telling you the button who
is so decorative I didn't consider
replacing the buttons and for all the
other buttons but it I needed for the
same button which I didn't if with all
the respect have you heard of 3d
printing I have well with all due
respect I'm not as rich as you I don't
know just to pick up on that and it
reminds me of being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
reminds me of my mother
[Laughter]
that reminds me of the first time that I
went to meet your parents and I was the
very very first time ever and I had this
weird thing about me that I don't have
anymore here you go and I don't know
what what caused it but I guess it was
morning ritual away or what caused it to
be it what caused it to go away I don't
know but I used to have a certain time
limit from the time I woke up to the
time I had a cup of coffee where if I
didn't get a cup of coffee within two
hours of waking up I would just start
crying and like it was not controllable
like it would just come out of my face
it started I guess in high school
because something that you're a child no
I started drinking coffee when I was 14
and then like after a few years of
drinking and everyday I think I just
yeah I got addicted to it but it became
a time limit we're like at a certain
point I just would start crying like not
not sad I wasn't sad or logical I would
just start tears would just start coming
out and the first time I met his parents
they really lag all when they say
they're gonna go somewhere and
they had us wake up super early to go
see his movie but this movie yeah yeah
my dad has to get the [ __ ] deal my
old man loves to get the man maybe it's
a gag at the matinee how early it was
9:00 a.m. well there's nothing to get
there but 10:00 a.m. is when the movie
starts 4:10 a anyway like we it was more
it was more than two hours and I just
started crying around them yes his mom
cries a lot
all the day the most normal shouldn't
that ever happened to my family like
wait a woman crying in her house yeah
he's saying how his parents move really
slow remind me my how my parents are
starting to move slower so her - yeah
it's just like they don't like
physically move not lagging oh my family
came home looking like oh man yo my dad
moves really fast oh I think he still
got like the mobility mobility but my
mom like I see her she's starting to
slow down alive she walks down the
stairs really really slow and kind of
like okay every year every time I see
them it's just like a change you liked
thinking about your own mortality yeah
it does you kind of reminds me I don't
know again they also kind of softened
you up a little bit when you see your
own parents kind of go through the
changes oh yeah and then kind of makes
you kind of go into the state of what
compassionate thing online about like
that's like the most painful thing as a
child is seeing your parents get older
yeah kind of like watching your heroes
like change you know or like not not
become like the crazy like superheroes
that you like imagine them to be all the
time douche I feel like it makes you
less than a douche like make it mate I
think it made me less of a douche like I
kind of appreciate them more I'd like to
talk to them more now when were you
would do
I'll call bark wanna douche any day of
the week
you be the douche that's hard I know
what do you mean because you would he
would even call his parents back for a
long time like that yeah shady son juice
to your son dis your parents yeah
speaking of parents it's funny fun
stories about our parents is my dad has
a story about his crap like watching
like your parents get older as I'm
watching my grandfather get older but
the funniest story that I remember from
those particular stories is that my
grandfather loves going to Vegas right I
wonder where I get it from but good guy
like Marcus oh yeah so he would go to
Vegas but he's getting older Morrissey
now he would forget like where he puts
the cash out vouchers or whatever so
that he's like puts them in his back
pocket shuffling down the casino floor
and my dad's like yeah just be like like
walking behind him like picking up
[ __ ] gonna do any of that [ __ ] he was
like a kind of like a wallet in pockets
why do I need to need that kind of [ __ ]
speed of agency reminds me of Nicky's
grandma man we like going to Vegas with
her cuz Filipina her Filipino grandma
she sits there at the paints loss and
she doesn't move for like five hours but
it's a specific yes and she gets very
cranky if it's not that has to be did
that salon buffalo buffalo go that slot
at that casino yeah it's like - oh yeah
that's your that's her machete so then
when she's when she's betting right she
touches the ones that she wants to
happen oh yeah she has a ritual she was
a ritual that's awesome so you watch her
slapping the screen yeah and she goes
now nowadays with with Cardona like she
really shouldn't be doing this [ __ ] yeah
Oh true so hopefully she won't but like
but if we saw your hands
did you disinfect it maybe then she can
we'll see we'll see that would wash the
magic away yeah you can't do that
I love how old people have these things
like I know that like there are certain
older guys will bleep play craps yeah
there's certain guys were like yo you
gotta blow on these dice like it's not
even garden don't trust anyone that
doesn't have a rituals with crab I love
the rich they're newbies like me joy has
his dice ritual and I started doing that
after b2i selfie tweeted and I've had
some killer role since then so I think
that hey you having a rituals there's
something sexy and cool and like it's
almost purposeful about it or like like
almost like the secret where you're like
I have the intention of killing it for
this table yeah because I'm taking it
more seriously maybe it is working for
something crystal your energy into that
yeah it's just about positive vibes that
seems to work pretty well you bringing
up the secret it reminds me and also
gambling it reminds me of a time when
it's many times every time I want to win
something like if there's like a raffle
happening or like some sort of contest
or in gambling like even with craps
every time I want it really really
really badly I don't get it yeah but
then every time that I'm like you know
what [ __ ] I'm not even gonna get it
this time then it's like a perfect roll
and I'm like how do I do this all the
time I feel like I needed be drunk
before gambling because of that reason
like it makes me not cares like a
superstition to it too so you're just
like well obviously I have to drink now
or else I'm gonna lose money okay $50
for these games all these when I'm sober
yeah there's a there's a correlation
meanwhile you look at your balance even
though this is gonna get some shots
biggest pack of correlation okay I'm
gonna get I'm gonna take it down to see
it I'm gonna take it too serious more
okay I don't want to get serious all day
get serious I miss you I miss you guys
it's been a very serious time in the
world and I think it's times like this
where we feel like we could lose
everybody that we love that that we
should say some nice things to each
other the end I really do mean this is
sounds like I'm doing I'm preparing for
a bit I know that but it's not really
that keep doing his trolls I'm not doing
that
I know but I'm putting myself in there
mentally as you guys judge me but I'm
not really there I think Steve's being
sincere genuinely I'm so proud of you
guys I love you guys you guys [ __ ]
made it work in a way that I don't think
any of us thought that you guys would
[Applause]
there was a date if came and stayed with
us I thought you guys will near the
ropes right like I really did I told you
guys that I'm so proud of you guys for
coming through the other side I'm so
happy for you guys really genuinely I am
you're you're a great man I love you
like a brother you're you're you're a
better person than I think people
realize they see is a meathead [ __ ]
dump your you are the mushiya stucking
guy you have no man you both are such
motion it's all love notes right do
robotic leagues like okay Mondays for
Nikki means it means that that's
something Robert Ryan I couldn't know a
[ __ ] Joker cooler dude than you I
really couldn't met like you are you are
a [ __ ] like cool tech I really think
I appreciate that you came into this
company and got us all to drink
you know I've bought you a smartest
person anything I just love you guys I
serious times and I just want I just
want everyone to know that on the way
this is the last time but you're seeing
a group of people together right now
you've been going crazy serious
no I am I know I mean no I just think
it's important because sometimes we we
get so mired in the bits right that you
know we're all trying to want each other
do bunch of comedy with which that loves
to about this place it was really so
excited to come here you [ __ ] wait
yeah well you you we all take it for
granted right that we even get to come
here like we all take it for granted or
that we even get to do you do this is
our job to come here and do this and
hang out with a friend's Hank do our
podcast with all you guys and all this
stuff that we get to do I'm just so
thankful because we could be at the end
we really could be like this could be it
like for all I know and I don't think
about write about life per se but the
way that the economy could shift all the
stuff we know yeah yeah I just I just
appreciate this time in this place and
these people and I know they aren't
important to say it sometimes because
and I think that I hope that a lot of
you do too I hope a lot of you
opportunity to be to your people too
because it matters so subscribe you
please and okay and donate on patreon to
help you
[Music]
[Music]